so und jetzt schauen wir auf
Katerstimmung heute bei der CDU in
Niedersachsen die Partei von
Spitzenkandidat Bernd altusmann verliert
deutlich und zwar über fünf Prozent das
heißt die CDU fliegt mit aller
Wahrscheinlichkeit im hohen Bogen raus
aus der letzten großen Koalition in
Deutschland und Bert Althusmann selbst
der Chef der Niedersachsen CDU erklärt
noch am Abend seinen Rücktritt tja der
Frust ist also groß auch bei der FDP ja
die ziehen gar nicht in den Landtag ein
die Liberalen sind krachen gescheitert
an der 5% Hürde eine Niederlage
natürlich auch für den FDP-Chef im Bund
für Christian Mettner
wir haben heute für die Freien
Demokraten einen traurigen Abend wir
haben ein politischen Rückschlag
erlitten unser Ziel war klar wir wollten
eine linke Mehrheit eine linke Koalition
in Hannover verhindern nach allem wonach
es aussieht er wird die Mitte nicht
gestärkt sondern Niedersachsen wird nach
links gehen das war das was wir
verhindern wollten lange Gesichter bei
der FDP gute Laune aber dahingegen bei
den Grünen sie fahren fast sechs Prozent
mehr ein 14,5 Prozent und damit die
Hoffnung auf Regierungsbeteiligung in
Hannover Rot-Grün in Niedersachsen ja
mit deutlichen Vorsprung ging auch die
SPD am Sonntagabend bei der Landtagswahl
in Niedersachsen über die Ziellinie sie
bleibt stärkste Kraft und stellt auch
künftig in Hannover den
Ministerpräsidenten Stefan weil
so und darüber müssen wir natürlich
jetzt sprechen mit CSU landesgruppenchef
Alexander Dobrindt er uns zugeschaltet
live schönen guten Tag Herr Dobrindt
hallo grüß Gott also man muss ja schon
sagen Herr Dobrindt die Verlierer von
Berlin also die SPD und auch die Grünen
das sind die Gewinner von Hannover wie
erklären Sie sich das nach dieser
Grotten schlechten Performance sowohl
der Kanzler als auch der Habeck
beteiligt
in der Tat was ist ein sehr schwieriges
Ergebnis was gestern erzielt worden ist
sind Niedersachsen für die CDU und es
zeigt dass die Mobilisierung nicht
geklappt hat wenn man sich die
wählerbewegungen anschaut dann ist ja
auch auffällig dass es einen erheblichen
Strom gegeben hat zu Nichtwählern und
das ist der Beleg dafür dass
Mobilisierung nicht wirklich
funktioniert hat dass die anderen
offensichtlich mit ihren Themen besser
punkten konnten und dass man ja die
schwierige Lage der Ampel in Berlin
nicht wirklich nutzen konnte als Union
nicht wirklich nutzen konnte andere
haben ja leider davon profitiert sie
haben es gerade angesprochen die
wählerbewegungen da ging aber auch
einiges von der CDU zur AFD wie erklären
Sie sich das
ich sage ja andere haben leider davon
profitiert das heißt es gibt natürlich
aufgrund der mangelnden politischen
Entscheidungen in Berlin durch die Ampel
in den vergangenen Monaten
Unzufriedenheiten aber vor allem auch
Angst es gibt Ängste in der Bevölkerung
und diese Ängste die mit Überforderung
zu tun haben also Angst vor finanzieller
Überforderung weniger steigenden Preise
wegen steigender Energiepreise vor allem
wo die Ampel bisher ja keine Antworten
hatte diese Angst wurde offensichtlich
bei der AFD dann hinterlegt die hat
deutlich davon profitiert und
offensichtlich ist es anderen nicht
gelungen Rezepte darzustellen die die
Wähler dazu bewegt haben dann Union zu
wählen es war eine krachende Niederlage
für die FDP Christian Lindner wäre jetzt
die Rolle in der ampelkollektion noch
mal überdenken welchen Rat geben Sie
dafür den Liberalen
es steht mir fern der Ratschläge zu
geben aber es ist ja erkennbar dass die
FDP ihre Rolle in der Ampel nicht
wirklich gefunden hat dass sie ein
Glaubwürdigkeitsproblem hat dass er für
all die Dinge für diese ja eigentlich
klassisch steht nämlich solide Finanzen
und Wirtschaft dass sie das nicht
wirklich in der Ampel mit umsetzen kann
entlastungsversprechen konnten nicht ja
umgesetzt werden auch das was jetzt
immer von den fdp-kollegen hier im Bund
erzählt wird dass ihr die kalte
Progression bekämpfen das wurde in der
Vergangenheit ja gerade von der FDP
immer Selbstverständlichkeit dargestellt
also kann man jetzt auch nicht daraus
einen großen Erfolg machen und ja die
FDP Christian Lindner wir haben sie
gerade gehört spricht ja selber davon
dass SPD und Grüne eine linke Partei
sind ja und mit diesen beiden linken
Parteien mit denen arbeitet er jetzt
zusammen eben in Berlin in einer Ampel
in einer Regierung und hat
offensichtlich als FDP noch nicht die
Kraft gefunden diese wenigen Parteien
auf einen Mittelkurs zu bringen also zu
viel linke Projekte in der Ampel zu
wenig durch die FDP verhindert dass es
wohl eines der Hauptprobleme da gibt es
ja Nachholbedarf einfach für die FDP was
das eigene Profil anbelangt was bedeutet
das denn ihrer Meinung nach für den
Zustand der Ampel wie lange wird die
Regierungskoalition denn noch halten
ich glaube das jetzt ein bisschen zu
weit gegriffen diese Frage zu stellen
sondern die werden schon irgendwie
versuchen müssen sich zusammen zu raufen
aber es darf auf Dauer in einer
Regierung nie so gehen dass einer der
ist der die Lasten zu tragen hat und die
schlechteste Ergebnisse einzufahren hat
sondern es müssen am Schluss natürlich
alle ja profitieren können wenn das
nicht der Fall ist wird eine Regierung
instabil und das droht hier natürlich
auf der einen Seite durch das nicht
handeln durch die wirklich schwierige
Performance vom Wirtschaftsminister
Habeck der ein ganz schlechte Rolle in
der Energie Frage auch spielt und das
mangelnde Profil der FDP das zusammen
ist dann schon eine Mischung die auch so
eine Bundesregierung in schweres
Fahrwasser bringen kann bisher hat der
Bundeskanzler versucht ja das
auszugleichen ist ihm ja auch immer
wieder in Teilen gelungen aber ob das
dauerhaft der Fall ist da habe ich
erhebliche Zweifel ich glaube es wird
sich was ändern und die FDP der
Generalsekretär der FDP hat er gestern
auch angekündigt ist müssen liberale
Themen stärker in dieser Regierung Platz
finden und es müssen einfach auch mal
linke Themen verhindert werden bisher
macht die FDP ja auch immer alles mit
und daraus kann man dann auch kein
eigenes Profil gewinnen jetzt muss man
allerdings auch mal über die CDU
sprechen die offensichtlich auch ein
bisschen Profil los geworden ist wir
haben es eben schon angesprochen eine
große wählerwechsel hin zur AFD muss die
Union muss die CDU jetzt nicht mal
anfangen bisschen lernen ihr Profil
wieder ein bisschen zu schärfen um diese
Wähler wieder einzufangen auf der
rechten Seite
wir haben ja in diesem Jahr auch große
Wahlerfolge eingefahren als Union also
die CDU in Nordrhein-Westfalen die CDU
in Schleswig-Holstein hat starke
Wahlergebnisse eingefahren das heißt es
ist wohl regional auch sehr
unterschiedliches hat was mit der
Mobilisierung zu tun das heißt das
Profil muss dann auch an die
wählerangebracht werden und mit den
richtigen Themen besetzt werden das ist
eben jetzt in Niedersachsen anscheinend
so nicht gelungen in NRW und in
Schleswig-Holstein ist das ja auch
gelungen das heißt die CDU die Union hat
das Profil die CDU und die CSU gemeinsam
haben ja auch ihre Rolle in Berlin in
der Opposition angenommen wir sind die
Herausforderer für diese ampelregierung
wir stellen das auch jede Woche unter
Beweis aber es hat offensichtlich nicht
ausgereicht in Niedersachsen jetzt alle
Wähler dann an die Wahlurne zu bringen
die man als Unterstützer braucht
und deswegen ja muss man aus dieser
Situation heraus schlichtweg lernen
stärker einen mobilisierungswahlkampf zu
fahren dazu gehört auch dann ein
bisschen Mut auf klare Themen zu setzen
klare Kante zu haben nicht manche Themen
vielleicht auszulassen das bringt am
Schluss keine Zustimmung deswegen ein
etwas stärkerer Wahlkampf auf
spezifische Themen ausgerichtet mit mehr
Mut dass es sicher das was für die
Zukunft notwendig ist
schon so ein bisschen den Eindruck dass
die Union ihre nach rechts abgewandelten
Wähler so ein bisschen abschreibt wie
gefährlich ist das
nein erstens das findet ja nicht statt
es werden überhaupt keine Wähler
abgeschrieben aber es gibt Themen die
nicht so ganz leicht zu besetzen sind
nicht ganz leicht wie das andere machen
wir sind ja eine
kritische aber eine konstruktive
Opposition und offensichtlich war die
Unsicherheit durch dieses nichthandelnde
Ampel gerade im Energiebereich auch so
groß dass es einfach Wählerschichten
gegeben hat die am Schluss sehr stark
den Protest wählen wollten und weniger
Interesse hatten an konstruktiven
Vorschlägen das kann man aus der
Situation der Angst heraus dann auch
erklären das verändert sich auch wieder
wenn man ja wie zum Beispiel jetzt auch
dann aus der Regierung heraus Vorschläge
macht wie gegen diese Energiekrise
vorgegangen werden kann wenn sich da
etwas Beruhigung zeigt dann ist auch
wieder die Bereitschaft glaube ich bei
den Wählern da anders zu reagieren aber
erstmal hat der Protest bei einem Teil
natürlich auch ja schlichtweg gebirgt
oder es war die Ausdrucksform die da
gegeben werden wollte zum Thema
Energiekrise noch eine Frage mit bitte
um kurze Antwort die gaspreiskommission
die schlägt ja jetzt vor Bürger und
Wirtschaft in zwei Schritten zu
unterstützen mit einer Einmalzahlung in
Höhe von der Dezember Gasrechnung und
dann auch noch mit einer staatlichen
Subvention macht die Union damit
naja also bisher haben wir ja immer
festgestellt dass die ampelregierung
keinen großen Wert legt auf unsere
Mitarbeit wir haben das ja jetzt
mehrmals angeboten in den vergangenen
Wochen darauf wurde entweder nicht
reagiert oder zumindest nicht positiv
reagiert wir haben gezeigt dass wir
konstruktiv mitarbeiten können als wir
diese 100 Milliarden
Sondervermögen wie es heißt also
sonderschulden für die Bundeswehr
möglich gemacht haben mit einer
Verfassungsänderung aber bei diesen
Energiefragen hat man uns jetzt nicht
beteiligt man geht auf unsere Vorschläge
ein die gaspreisbremse ist ja ein
Vorschlag der Union den wir schon vor
Monaten gemacht haben daran sieht man
auch schon dass die Ampel reichlich spät
jetzt reagiert für viele ist es schon
sehr teuer geworden und ich habe die
Befürchtung das mit dieser Einmalzahlung
jetzt quasi im Dezember dieses Jahres
dann die eigentlichen Kosten für die
Haushalte nicht wirklich aufgefangen
werden die ja Periode die Heizperiode
geht ja Oktober November Dezember und
auch Januar Februar und da nur an einem
einzigen Monat eine Lösung zu finden die
anderen Monate ungelöst lassen obwohl
viele Haushalte das Zehnfache gerade an
Abschlägen Bezahlen von dem was sie
früher bezahlt haben das glaube ich ist
wahrscheinlich keine ausreichende Lösung
das kann im nächsten Jahr dann besser
werden ab März wenn der zweite Schritt
dann so kommen sollte aber bisher sind
wir die großen Kosten erstmals mit
dieser Einmalzahlung aus meiner Sicht
noch keine ausreichende Lösung gefunden
sagt CSU-Landesgruppenchef Alexander
Dobrindt danke dass Sie sich die Zeit
genommen haben
ich danke Ihnen
[Musik]